There's this neuroscientist,
you're a psychologist
named El Conan Goldberg,
and Goldberg was a student of Alexander
Luria and Alexander Luria was a Russian
neuropsychologist,
perhaps the foremost neuro psychologist
of the mid to late 20th century.
And he had students Sokolov in vinegar
Dova who discovered the orienting reflex.
For example,
the orienting reflects is the reflex
that orients you win something anomalous,
interferes with your
goal directed behavior.
It's a major discovery,
like one of the,
one of the four or five most important
discoveries that have ever been made in,
in,
in psychology,
I would say,
certainly in neuroscience.
So Luria was a big deal and he was the
first person who really established the
functional role of the
prefrontal Cortex as well.
So,
and had it very nice overall
view of how the brain functioned.
His book was written
in 1980 and it's still,
there's still lost in it.
That's really useful,
which is pretty strange for a
science that's advanced that quickly.
Anyways,
so Goldberg came from a great pedigree,
I believe Larry,
his teacher was Pavlov,
if I remember correctly.
So anyways,
um,
Goldberg,
you know,
you hear,
some of you may have heard the idea that
the left hemisphere is more linguistic
than the right hemisphere is that left
hemisphere is specialized for language
and the right hemisphere is
specialized for nonverbal images,
stick communication.
The left hemisphere has a pretty
well organized micro structure and the
right hemisphere is more diffuse as well.
And
that's true in lefthanded
males in particular.
So the circuitry can be
switched around a bit,
but it's okay.
The modules are basically the same,
although they can be moved a little bit,
but Goldberg thought that it isn't
language versus non language,
it's routine versus novelty.
And so the left hemisphere and there's a
neuropsychologist physician named Roman
[inaudible] who's done
some very interesting work,
um,
that's pertinent to this.
Maybe I'll tell you a story about him.
Anyways,
Goldberg believed that
the Right Hemisphere,
let's say you have very
old systems underneath,
boast both cortical hemispheres that do
things like respond to anomaly to the
thing that doesn't fit to
the Predator in the distance.
Some of that's extraordinarily fast.
So that would be like a snake reflects
that can move you away from a snake in
less time than it takes the snake to bite.
And it's really a reflex.
It doesn't even hit your brain.
It's really super fast.
And then there's a
defensive crouch that's,
that's instantiated higher
up in the nervous system.
But that's still remarkably fast.
And then there's fear as an emotion and,
and the orientation of attention.
And then there's the cognitive processing
and that all streams out across a
timespan,
right?
And maybe that time span is half a second.
So,
and that's really a long time
if something is attacking you.
So you got those initial
responses are quite primitive,
but they're extraordinarily fast.
All right?
So there's subcortical structures that
orient you towards novelty and prepare
you for,
for freezing or for attending.
And the right hemisphere seems
to be dominated by those systems.
So imagine that what happens is
that something threatens you.
You Orient towards it.
The right hemisphere produces a bunch
of images about what it might be.
So imagine that's what happens
when a child is afraid of the dark.
The child's on the bed,
they're afraid of the dark,
they're crouched cause they're
frozen like a prey animal.
And their right hemisphere is producing
monsters to inhabit the darkness that
are the child's hypotheses
about what might be out there.
Okay.
Because that's what you want to know,
right?
You want to know what's out there and
then you want to know what to do about it.
I can tell you two kids' dreams
that are sort of relevant to that.
So when my daughter was about three,
she came into the bedroom that my
wife and I had and she was crying,
she'd had a nightmare.
And she said that she saw a stream and
there was garbage all over the street.
And she didn't like that.
And so I sat her down and I said,
okay,
so imagine the stream
with the garbage in it.
Now imagine that you're taking the
garbage out and throwing it in the garbage
bin.
And so she,
and I got her to like visualize that
because that kind of puts her back in the
semi dream state.
And then she cleaned up the mess
and then she could go off to sleep.
Now you,
you could tell the child,
don't worry about the dream isn't real.
But that's not,
that's true because it's not real.
Like other day time things are,
but it's not like it's not real.
It's a dream.
Like a dream is real.
It's just not the same kind of real.
And so what I did with her was to indicate
to her practically that if she saw
something anomalous,
something that was out of place,
right?
Something that was a mass,
that it was within her capacity to set it.
Right.
Okay.
And so,
okay,
so now your right hemisphere tells
you what monster's might inhabit.
The,
the darkness.
Now what you have to do is figure out,
there's two things you have to figure out.
One is what to do about it given
monster and other is to do,
what about is to figure out what to do
about the class of all possible monsters,
right?
That's a whole different thing.
That's something that only
human beings are capable of.
That level of abstraction.
Right?
And so what you might do
about a particular monster
is hide or go out and get
rid of it if was just an actual animal.
Right?
But that doesn't help because they're
sold the other potential predators that
are still there.
And so maybe you can go hunt,
hold them down.
But that doesn't help either because
you can't hunt them all down.
It's not our,
it's not very likely anyways.
So instead what you have to do is figure
out how to configure yourself so that
you're in the best possible position to
fight off the monsters when they come.
That's your best bet.